Are you familiar with EBOO treatments and do you think it is something that I could do to help with live and cancer?
So EBOO is extra corp helial blood oxygenation in ozonation.
It is a therapy that is used.
You sit down and you connect a vein in your arm and basically are ozonating oxygenate your blood for a period of time.
It came out about 10-15 years ago as this very promising therapy.
And there are some cancer clinics that use the machinery still.
It hasn't really proven to be helpful to my understanding for cancer.
I think where it does shine is with lime.
Does it hinder cancer cared?
Could it be bad for some of your cancer?
No, I don't think so.
Can it be good for cancer?
Possibly it just hasn't shown that promise.
So primarily it's not used so much for cancer for cancer anymore.
But with lime disease or other infections that are stubborn infections, it can be helpful.
So yeah, no, I think that's just fine.
If you want to do it, I don't see any downsides.